the iheart radio music awards took over
at the shrine auditorium in los angeles
last night with jennifer lopez being
honored with the icon award celebrating
her impact on pop culture longevity and
continued relevance as a touring and
radio force with a loyal fan base
worldwide that sounds about right for j
though yeah it's about right she's
everything and fans weren't the only
ones cheering on jlo with her proud
boyfriend ben affleck all smiles
alongside his son samuel and jlo's
daughter emmy as jayla delivered an
emotional acceptance speech to her fans
because of you i get to do what i love
the most in life and
that is the most wonderful blessing
you guys are the ones who give me the
opportunity every day to live a life i
couldn't even imagine would come true
when i was a little girl growing up in
the bronx i know so i want to say
thank you to every one of you for
believing in me
when other people didn't even when i
didn't
and let me tell you something else
i'm just getting started
[Applause]
she's the best
just getting started huh just kidding
justin
i trust jayla when she says she's just
getting started all right now after
cementing her icon status jlo delivered
an electrifying performance to some of
her biggest hits
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah that's the blueprint right there
like if you are an aspiring pop star yep
you got to look down and go
you got to put in some work
i got to put in some work i've said this
before on the show jlo is the best human
on earth yeah if you took if you've been
on the planet best human on the planet
if you took all the things that make
people great right so you have talent
ambition being an inspirational person
uh looks charisma
charm smarts
humor
all of this stuff and if you took all
those qualities and then you put them in
like you started building a pyramid of
all the people in the world that have
all those qualities at the very top of
that pyramid would be jlo and she can
dance this is what i mean and she can do
this is what i mean it's all part of it
she's the greatest human on earth so
we've reached peak that's it that's so
this is the reason why we're going for
like ai and robotics now yes because we
can't do better humans no so we have to
make robot humans
because jlo exists thank you for coming
around the reason what is going on in
silicon valley right now is they are
nerds are spending
years and billions of dollars trying to
make a j lo
that's basically it right that's what
happened because it's not natural
everything she has
you need teams of people if you want to
even come close to replicating a jayla
you're talking about
best human being ever a lot of people in
our comments might agree with this
question
is she a dog person though oh i don't
know
i don't know does it but but do you care
even because she's so great yeah i don't
know i think dog or jlo um people dogs
are gene yeah i think it's even i think
it's even it's the other way around it's
the other way around right yeah
do you like j.lo and as you walk around
you're like you're out of here that's
how good she is
i love that i love that all right
congratulations jayla